nachdem in letzter zeit und in den
letzten videos so viel gutes widerfahren
ist ich habe unfassbar schnell viele
neue abonnenten griechen support von
euch dazu gekommen ich habe 800 euro im
casino gewonnen habe ich mich gefragt
was kann ich gut es zurückgeben und was
kann ich tun um hier mal ein richtig
positives zeichen zu setzen in der
letzten zeit ist uns einladen richtig
ans herz gewachsen und das just try out
your soul food hier in köln ehrenfeld
der hat einem food truck gestartet hat
jetzt seinen eigenen laden also es läuft
eigentlich schon ganz gut wenn man aber
seien in star und seinen öffentlichen
auftritt anguckt sieht man da gibt es
einigen verbesserungsbedarf also ist
maximal die idee gekommen dass wir uns
einen tag komplett darauf fokussieren
diesen laden komplett auf vordermann zu
bringen was karten fotos und kunden
angeht das bedeutet wir werden jetzt
hinfahren und probieren ihn davon zu
überzeugen dass wir sein laden komplett
neu ab filmen fotografieren im ennstal
content liefern
und heute abend alle leute die mir auf
insta folgen einladen da kostenlos auf
meinen nacken zu essen mit dem geld was
ich letzte woche im casino gewonnen habe
das herzig namen im riesen plan an
jetzt müssen wir erst mal hinfahren und
ihn davon überzeugen dass das wirklich
eine gute idee ist und schauen auf einer
xbox hofer wenn das funktioniert dann
müssen wir den ganzen tag geisteskrank
rheinhessen um seinen laden komplett auf
vordermann zu bringen also ich der
besitzer ricky ist so ein ehrenmann wenn
man auch bei ihm bestellt der kommt zu
dir nach hause hat sein sakko an wo er
sein eigenes logo drauf hatten er ist
sooo stolz alters durch einfach nur
eines immer nett der strahl so eine
positive energie aus und er das wirklich
verdient dass man ihm auch mal was
zurückgibt
der fußball scheint aber zu sein also
das hier ist wo alles gestartet ist
soweit ich das verstehe dann patrick die
uns aber wahrscheinlich gleich mehr zu
sagen
es ist einfach nur einfach nur irgendwie
so ehrlich schon sehen das sind
vielleicht die sachen die wir heute
angehen wollen um die ein bisschen
besser zu machen prinzip durch dieses
mit liebe gemacht aber es ist sowas
und das können wir alles besser machen
ich freue mich so ricky ist halt einfach
koch durch und durch mit vollem blut und
eben kein fotograf aber da kommen wir
dann ins spiel und helfen ihm dabei der
größte ehrendamen sind jetzt die nummer
organisiert berichtet tatsächlich nicht
in seinem laden ist aber wir werden ihn
schnell anrufen und ihm von seinem glück
überraschend oder ihn zumindest fragen
wann der kommt also ricky max hier wann
bist du im laden
[Applaus]
lasst uns gleich einmal kurz quatsch
wenn du da bist wirst du kannst du ganz
kurz der termin das alles angefangen hat
somit den mit dem food truck und sophia
2017 haben wir diese vision gehabt da
gibt's keine froh überhaupt in
deutschland machen gar nicht so schnell
restaurant sowie kerstin hatte ich meine
vision ist dass sie deswegen heißt oscar
cardozo fuß so sortiert
die sind alles motto fand die mission
davon da habe ich ein bordell war der
kommt von selbst gemacht mit einer sauce
und weise ist alles unglaublich in die
soße solche waffe wurde ziemlich
gebrachten qualität man sagen kommen
noch mehr noch mehr welche wegen so
weiter und da hat jetzt drei jahre lang
maßnahme muss freitag so haben wir die
erste waren diese schon gerade hier das
klassische 242 in korn genommen der herz
auf dem feld mit beste laden aufgemacht
am 17 april locken dann kann er gemacht
durch diego für lief es ähnlich wir sind
die erste abfahrt es optisch war das bis
auf das funktioniert ja nicht nur ein
gutes essen hat sondern weil man merkt
dass es ist ja wirklich so gut und dass
ihr dabei seid und das komplett für die
betriebe nach richtige wochen gesehen
und richtig
sie ist nur einfach media gewonnen
wie sie war diakon abläuft korrelation
und verzierungen abstand 1 5 bis 2 muss
dass ich wichtig es ist dir sagen uns
nicht was nicht stoppen habe ich einen
blog in kuba die kurse nun jetzt nur
noch neue neuere bilder und heute abend
ganz später sowie die gerade hier genau
gebaut haben ist aber vielleicht mit
honig so sind dass honig so sie kommt
von ricky mache ich alles selbst das
knaller kommt vorbei hier sehr wichtig
dass man die beste essen können wir
kommen so und witziges suchen
neben mamas küche gerade interview mit
ricky gehabt ganz aufgegeben hat hier
alles zu filmen und zu machen der
liefert gerade essen aus und jetzt
steuern wir hier den ganzen tag um und
machen alles ready an bildern fotos und
machen das hier alles auf allerhöchstem
wenn man natürlich gemerkt ich stolz
ricky darüber ist und ob man kann auch
stolz sein ist einfach geil was hier auf
die beine gestellt haben ist ein schöner
ganz einfach herzlich das essen ist gut
ski fährt gerade noch essen aus kommt
jetzt gleich aber wieder und wird dann
für mich kochen so dass sie auch
fotografieren und filmen kann max fährt
in der zeit schon zum baumarkt und holt
so hintergründe und untergründe an holz
und schieferplatten die wir für die
bilder benutzen könnte arbeitsteilung
hier und dann werden gleich die kosten
bilder und das erste video gedreht und
dann heute abend wenn ihr mir bei insta
gefolgt hätte werdet ihr auch dabei
gewesen
könnt ihr auf meinen nacken hier fressen
hat den wir dann extra in dem baumarkt
gefahren sind um video und foto
hintergründe zu kaufen um rickys essen
im besten licht überhaupt dastehen
lassen zu können haben wir den ganzen
tag geisteskrank rheingasse wir haben
fotos gemacht wir haben videos gedreht
um das werbevideo zu drehen um fotos zu
haben für rookies instagram und website
und wenig moderiert weil wir einfach
wirklich krass gearbeitet ich kann jetzt
zwei stunden komplett durchgearbeitet
bin in zwölf minuten mit
wir sind im rennen dann gerade bei 4 ich
habe eine version im querformat eine
version im hochformat für seine story
und jetzt zeige ich erstmal was wir
alles für den gemacht haben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hier sehen
deswegen komme wo die mitte gesucht
immer genug davon das komplette video
könnt ihr in der video beschreibung auch
nicht gelistet anschauen das hier sind
die bilder sehr nice in ausgedruckter
form auch nochmal hier wir machen uns
jetzt aber auf dem schnellsten wege
zurück bevor ich dann die ergebnisse von
dem ganzen tag arbeit gezeigt habe habe
ich ihm erst mal die frohe botschaft
verkündet das frohe botschaft verkündet
wird wer jesus geboren
die frohe botschaft verkündet dass alle
leute die heute abend von mir in sein
restaurant kommen kostenlos auf meinen
nacken essen werden und ich glaube das
hat ihn richtig gefreut also ich habe
gedacht vielleicht kannst du kleines
gemacht damit die leute wissen wer hier
was ist was sagst du gefällst hier sind
die jungen
und dann haben wir den abend bei ricky
mit freunden verbracht alle haben auf
meinen mac gegessen rickys er im food
hat extrem gut geschmeckt wir waren alle
mega happy ich finde das video ist ein
voller erfolg und ist ein sehr gutes von
dort zu den leicht negativ angehauchten
videos mit glücksspiel und cannabis die
sonst ab und zu kommen ich bin extrem
happy dass video ist nur positiv wenn
euch das video so gut gefallen hat mir
dann lasst mir gerne ein leichter wenn
euch das essen zusagt dann schaut gerne
bei ricky in der video beschreibung
vorbei so berater straße 2 in köln
absoluter ehrenmann fällt mir auf jeden
fall bei instagram da kommt bald was
noch größeres wo er nur teilnehmen
können wenn ihr mir folgt und das sofort
sehen wenn ich das in meiner story post
seid also ready vielen dank an max für
die ganze unterstützung bei dem video
cous cous cous mittwoch oder sonntag
geht's weiter vergesst nicht zu
abonnieren
bis dann